thank you all for joining us for the
president's annual update as I think
most of you know there are lots of
different ways in which the president
interacts with different parts of campus
but twice a year we make a special
effort to open it up to all faculty
staff and students and related Friends
of the University in this in the spring
we hear from dr. Suresh get an update on
achievements and advancements here at
the University and then in the fall we
have the annual town hall which is your
chance to ask your questions and hear
from the president in that format so
without any further ado we're still
getting some chairs and back but I think
we can get rolling as we're doing this
great to see you all here I'm delighted
to welcome to the stage our student body
president Flavia Nova
[Applause]
hi everybody I am extremely honored
today to give an introduction for dr.
Suresh he's been here for a little under
four years and in that short time he has
massively expanded Carnegie Mellon's
campus adding state-of-the-art
facilities resources and services in
broadening CMU's global enterprise of
course his accomplishments at Carnegie
Mellon are just a small part of his
extensive resume most of us have heard
of the impressive work that President
serratia has done serving as the
director of the National Science
Foundation under President Obama after
serving as the Dean of the School of
Engineering for the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology he is one of
only 19 americans and the only
university president in the national
academy for medicine the national
academy for sciences and the national
academy for engineering which is
impressive but a little intimidating
when you're trying to work up the
courage to ask him to take a selfie with
you but after working with President
Suresh over the course of this year i
can say that he extends far bikes beyond
the accomplishments that i've listed he
has kind to everybody regardless of
standing his dedication to serving and
improving Carnegie Mellon exemplifies
his humility his dedication oh excuse me
he continues actively learning and
listening never assuming his experience
is perfectly aligned with the truth and
perhaps most important he consistently
embraces a warm bright sense of humor
even in the most difficult situations
President Suresh is the best of what I
imagine it means to be part of the
Carnegie Mellon community and while it
took him a little while to realize it
himself she's plaid to the bone please
join me in welcoming the ninth president
of carnegie mellon university dr subra
Suresh
Thank You vasa week for your very kind
introduction it's wonderful to see
friends and colleagues from across the
campus over here today I also want to
acknowledge members of the senior
leadership team and a number of deans
who are here today thank you all for
coming and I would also acknowledge want
to acknowledge the presence of my boss
my wife Mary Suresh who's here I know I
know some of you are here because you
feel that if you don't come to my update
i may not come to your update and as
Yogi Berra the famous American
philosopher once said he always went to
other people's funerals because he felt
that if you didn't go to their funerals
they wouldn't come to his funeral that
is what is called a test joke because I
said that last year and I want to see if
you remember it from last year and if
you don't remember if you didn't come
here last year so good afternoon
everybody for the 2017 annual update in
addition to all of you who are gathered
here today I would also like to welcome
our online audience of students faculty
staff alumni parents and incoming and
prospective parents for prospective
students students who don't know yet
that they will be students of Carnegie
Mellon University we are pleased that
all of you are joining here today we
come each year to the community in two
very different distinct formats in the
fall we have a town hall where the
primary purposes for me to address
questions and concerns and thoughts that
you have in the spring we have a
different format as for example today
we're on behalf of
the campus and the entire leadership
team I present to you an annual update
to provide insight into recent
university developments and provide a
peek into our future let me start by
recognizing some very significant CMU
accomplishments by faculty and students
over the past six months or so among our
faculty Tepper School of Business
professors free that tie or was elected
to the National Academy of Engineering
last month I just saw three there
somewhere here sweeter please stand up
since I know you are here is in the back
because it's public information I am not
embarrassing freezer by saying this in
addition to being a pioneering
researcher in this field at the tepper
school of business in addition to being
very well accomplished in his profession
and well known globally and being an
outstanding entrepreneur who has started
successful companies see there gave a
million dollars to the construction of
tempered quad building so thank you sir
[Applause]
he and I went to the same undergraduate
school and he has been equally generous
to that institution as well he a few
years after I did professor Raj Raj
Kumar of the Department of Electrical
and Computer Engineering was named a
fellow of the National Academy of
inventors Peter Cook head of the school
of drama was named a member of the Order
of Australia in the Australia Day honors
list if you see him next please call him
Sir Peter and professor Mahdi Greiner of
the Heinz College was elected to the
National Academy of Medicine last
October and last but not least just a
few months ago computer science faculty
members Justine Castle manual of El Oso
and Todd Maori they were named 2016
association of computing machinery or
ACM fellows these are great honors among
our student body a group of CMU students
took eight plays out of more than 2,500
participants in the Hyperloop
competition initiative created by elon
musk I had the pleasure of spending some
time with him a number of months ago and
it's a very very impressive team
students in our entertainment Technology
Center won the people's choice award at
the Chi play conference on
human-computer interaction for their
work with a virtual reality experience
team last year and krystal thomas a
senior in a melon college of science was
named to the 2016 class of Schwartzman
scholars and she'll she'll be spending a
year in Beijing as one of the members of
a very prestigious cohort of college
graduates next year and among our CMU
student-athletes senior basketball
player Lisa Murphy surpassed 2000 career
points
and 1,000 career rebounds becoming the
only CMU player the only player in the
University Athletic Association and only
the 18th player in all of NCAA Division
three history to reach those milestones
congratulations
and that's not all in addition Lisa and
fellow senior Jackie hood poll were
named to the Academic all-district
women's basketball team by the college
sports information directors of America
for the second straight year our men's
and women's track and field teams won
the denison university bob shannon
invitational last month with the men
winning it for the second straight year
and in keeping with our wonderful
tradition here at carnegie mellon which
we have started celebrating and we did
that for the third year in December when
you do anything for three years it
becomes a tradition and it will continue
to be a carnegie mellon tradition in
keeping with that tradition 77 of our
student athletes posted 4.0 grade point
averages last semester and i don't think
any school can claim that kind of a
student athlete scholar reputation in
the country congratulations
[Applause]
there is no better time to be at
Carnegie Mellon University why CMU why
now the world we live in today our
global society is now considered to be
in the very early stages of being
completely transformed but by what has
been broadly referred to by leaders and
shapers of technologies as industry 4.1
4.0 or the fourth Industrial Revolution
it represents at this point in human
history the unprecedented convergence of
the physical the cyber and the
biological world this convergence has
included an unprecedented pace of change
that will have a profound impact on the
lives and the livelihoods of individual
citizens of the world it will also have
a profound impact on institutions
industries and Nations the key
ingredients of this revolution include
robotics artificial intelligence and
data science the Internet of Things
technology connecting with human
behavior and humanity human emotions
human psychology autonomous systems
ethics and policy Carnegie Mellon many
pioneered many key ingredients of these
areas over the past several decades how
successful we are as a human race in the
years and decades to come will depend
critically are not only how we maximise
the intended benefits of this rapid
change but equally how we minimize the
unknown drawbacks the known drawbacks
and the unintended consequences of these
technology
our successes then will depend
critically on collective efforts for
which Carnegie Mellon is globally
recognized not only pioneering
discoveries in science and engineering
computing robotics etc all the items
that I mentioned but equally in the
consequences of technology on humanity
areas such as ethics policy economics
labor business decision sciences
psychology interface of technology with
the Fine Arts privacy confidentiality
cyber security so on and so forth it is
for thus that reason I strongly believe
and many of us in this room believe that
Carnegie Mellon is uniquely positioned
to impact the global society more so
than at any other point in our long and
distinguished history this unique
combination of excellence and strengths
covering many dimensions of the human
condition is the reason we are receiving
increasingly greater attention from
industries that want to locate in
Pittsburgh close to our campus federal
government creating major entities that
are led by Carnegie Mellon University
greater visibility and engagement for
CMU in gatherings such as the World
Economic Forum major presence at events
such as the Tony Awards on Broadway and
growing number of key intellectual
centers funded at CMU by the private
sector as I address you today the
university is fully engaged in advancing
our strategic priorities attracting and
retaining outstanding and diverse talent
enhancing the CMU experience and
building excellence all across Carnegie
Mellon as you can see
the implementation of the University
strategic plan will touch everyone at
Carnegie Mellon faculty staff students
alumni parents etc our strengths in
education research and creativity impact
the economic and cultural life of the
Pittsburgh region the nation and the
world as we pursue strategic
partnerships and focus on solving
societal challenges and raise global
visibility for the university attracting
and retaining outstanding and diverse
talent necessarily requires building a
healthy and growing endowment and since
I last spoke to you in the fall at my
town hall we as a community have made
great strides let me give you some data
let's start with some recent numbers and
let's look at it historically our
university was founded in nineteen
hundred it took us about 107 years to
reach our first 1 billion dollars in
endowment in the year 2007 today our
total endowment as of December of 2016
our total endowment at Carnegie Mellon
was allocated to Carnegie Mellon has
surpassed two billion dollars for the
first time in our history this includes
permanent funds directly managed by us
and funds assigned to Carnegie Mellon
but managed out by outside entities in
the last three and a half years this
total value of our endowment has
increased by almost sixty percent thanks
to more than 450 contributors 255
current undergraduates and graduate
students at Carnegie Mellon now benefit
from an endowment for presidential
fellowships and scholarships the current
total value of which stands at 285
million dollars as part of this growing
endowment pool set aside in
perpetuity to benefit students we
announced a pledge from CMU trustee
Frank Bronkhorst for many presidential
scholarships for undergraduate students
with his new gift of ten million dollars
that was just announced this week
in the last few months we've also added
it to our permanent endowment many new
professorships for our outstanding
faculty members and these will be
allocated to professors in the becoming
few years for example this week we
announced a five-million-dollar gift for
the buncher chair for the head of the
school of music this is the largest gift
to the school of music in our history in
our efforts to better equip ourselves in
our quest to attract outstanding and
diverse talent we have added a new
cingular online portal that anyone from
the CMU community as well as faculty and
staff recruits students and the general
public can now get a better view of the
broader range of diversity and inclusion
efforts across the university we are
also building resources for staff
development and to support all our
efforts across CMU including leadership
training for staff and faculty just as
faculty and staff development and
diversity first efforts are drawing new
support other areas of the university
also continue to attract new support
from corporate governmental
institutional and individual partners
let me just give you a few examples that
have happened just in the last few
months or so a great example of this was
last November when we announced a 10
million dollar gift from K&L Gates to
study the policy and practical ethics of
artificial intelligence I mentioned
earlier that ethics and policy or key
ingredients of how technology will shape
our lives in the years and decades to
come CMU has unique strengths in this
area in the Dietrich college for example
and across the university and this was
recognized by the K&L gates gift last
fall
another gift from pricewaterhousecoopers
that could reach as much as thirty 1
million dollars over five years serves
to enhance our existing partnerships and
to create and support a new university
center the risk and regulatory services
Innovation Center led by the Hines
College of Public Policy and management
we also celebrated a 25 million dollar
gift from ansys a pittsburgh-area global
leader in engineering simulation which
will fund construction of a new
cornerstone building not just for the
engineering college but also for the
entire university community on our
campus to propel a growing maker
ecosystem Carnegie Mellon will receive
14 million dollars over the next five
years from the US Department of
Transportation to establish mobility 21
a new national university transportation
center that will focus on improving the
safety and efficient mobility of people
and goods in the 21st century we also
recently announced that the Department
of Defense and more than 100 partner
organizations have contributed together
more than 250 million dollars to what
was announced at the American robotics
an independent institute founded by
Carnegie Mellon University and located
in Pittsburgh to launch an advanced
robotics manufacturing Institute among
the most noteworthy gifts we have
received recently came in the form of
joint gifts from Carnegie Mellon
professors Josie murah and Manuel are
below so and Carnegie Mellon alumnus
Alec Kavcic and his wife Sofia their
collective gift of nineteen point five
million dollars to the University to
support education and research
activities in data science and
engineering and create a new endowed
fund to support inventors at Carnegie
Mellon reflects their deep commitment to
this university
it also reflects the opportunities and
support this university delivers to its
faculty students and staff these
critical resources come as we pursue the
broad but equally vital undertaking to
enhance the CMU experience that means
delivering the most secure supportive
and nurturing environment possible that
strengthens our community I see the CMU
experience as having two distinct but
interrelated dimensions the personal
dimension in environment and
infrastructure that allows each of us to
live healthy fulfilling lives and a
community dimension that creates a
united sense of spirit and purpose or a
dimension that many of us would like to
call one CMU our most recent development
in this endeavor has been a report from
the president's advisory board for the
CMU experience a standing committee
which met for the first time last
October the PAB has identified three
areas of focus change the stress culture
define and delivers a CMU experience
create the 1cm you experience this
report provides important direction and
context for our work seen through fresh
eyes and independent external
perspectives and measured against best
practices across the nation we will look
to implement measures that will address
the external advisory boards advice by
interfacing it with the work of the
internal task force for the CMU
experience which includes
representatives from all facets of the
university community faculty staff
students faculty senate staff council
and student bodies and this task force
has already began delivering invaluable
improvements that will impact the daily
lives of our students
we have a lot more work to do and the
work of this task force will continue
the CMU experience efforts are improving
the academic and advising infrastructure
of the university by exploring improved
course management providing students
with greater course information and
reviewing how course workloads aligned
with credits earned to increase student
success and building a community for our
international students and their
families is also equally important we
have created a new host family program
for international students this year
within the first few months of its
existence it has matched 73 students
international students with 40 host
families who serve as hosts and we
expect these numbers to increase
significantly based on the initial
interest that we have received both from
students and from the host families
there was a reception held for them just
a couple of weeks ago and it was
wonderful to be part of that event to
see the excitement and and the impact
that will come out of it in the
not-too-distant future our experiential
and programmatic enhancements will have
greater significance with the
improvements we are making to campus
infrastructure which helped build
community and allow us to do our very
best work these improvements and
renovations are taking shape all over
campus large and small to improve the
daily academic environment for faculty
and students a great example of this is
the renovation of the Sorel's
engineering and science library it win
hall which is significantly expanded the
amount of study and collaboration space
for students yesterday there was a an
opening of this and it was wonderful to
see the excitement in the face of
students along with Keith Webster and
farnam shahinian and others on what an
impact a seemingly small change in an
area can create for a large number of
two
the quality of the places where we work
learn and discover also has a profound
impact on the quality of the CMU
experience with that in mind the
university is pursuing a historic
expansion of its infrastructure and
upgrade of its classroom spaces
including the renovation of at least 10
classrooms in 2018 2019 academic year in
poznan Hall dsi a that will be made
available to the entire university
community and the addition of 23
classrooms in the new building a tapper
quadrangle and the hamburg hall these
developments along with the opening of
the TCS building also in 2018 the
answers Hall and the recently opened
Scott Hall also add new maker spaces and
collaborative spaces for the entire
campus community central to all these
efforts is the general health and
well-being of all of us in the carnegie
mellon university community i'm
delighted to report to you and i
mentioned this yesterday in the email
last week the Board of Trustees approved
the creation of a new health and
wellness center for the campus this
state of the art center will not only
double the size of CMU's current health
and wellness facilities it will allow
also allow us to reconsider less much
more broadly with programming that
supports physical mental and emotional
health student success counseling and
mentoring community engagement and one
CMU this is a major investment that will
put CMU at the forefront of student
support in the years to come by adding
outstanding talent and improving the
quality of the CMU experience will be
well positioned to tackle the third of
our strategic objectives building
excellence across the university we
start with a great advantage
consider for a moment the pillars of the
fourth Industrial Revolution which I
mentioned earlier that were pioneered at
the car at Carnegie Mellon University
they are they were all grounded in deep
scholarly fundamental scientific
research all across the university at
Carnegie Mellon that unilateral
excellence will be built on our historic
commitment to science this foundation
combined with technology business policy
design fine arts Social Sciences
architecture entrepreneurship and
Humanities makes this a great research
university well positioned to have a
powerful impact on the 21st century
human condition while we have always
emphasized science and encouraged
interdisciplinary science of our faculty
are now much more actively engaged in
encouraging students to expand outside
of their colleges and schools and reach
out to other areas of intellectual
pursuit while they are getting deep
disciplinary degrees in just the past
few months our scholarly excellence was
evident in a number of faculty alumni
and programmatic accolades we have a
long list i'll just mention a few of
them professor david Cresswell's
received the american psycho so
maximized sorry american psychosomatic
society's 2017 herbert weiner early
career award professor andre straw was
received the 2016 Phil Kaufman award for
distinguished contributions to
electronic system design from the
electronic system design Alliance and
the I Triple E Council on electronic
design automation and professor Takeo
kennedy became the first carnegie mellon
university professor to receive the 2017
I Triple E founders medal additionally
we've seen CMU recognized by industry
and
ngos and through achievements of our
alumni are go a i founded by former CMU
staff and students located right here in
Pittsburgh with other offices in
different parts of the country received
an investment of more than 1 billion
dollars from Ford just a couple of weeks
ago Carnegie Mellon University was
chosen to co-host to symposia in
partnership with the Carnegie Endowment
for international peace last fall in the
areas of digital governance and security
and several alumni were part of the
production crew that saw Frances receive
an Academy Award nomination for Best
Picture just last Sunday please join me
in celebrating the amazing
accomplishments of our faculty
I want to close by reiterating Carnegie
Mellon University's commitment to
diversity and in a community like ours
there are so many dimensions to
diversity within the past year our
campus community has continued to foster
diversity and inclusion through a number
of new and expanded efforts such as the
open forum hosted across the campus to
discuss topics related to diversity
anti-bias training sessions based on
best practices from across the country
and the formation of the most diverse
senior leadership team in our
University's history we also are
recommitting ourselves to creating
pipeline programs that prepare students
from underserved and underrepresented
communities for a rigorous higher
education whether it's at carnegie
mellon university or elsewhere this year
we will double the size of CMU's Summer
Academy for math and science program and
work is already underway and I
understand from Amy Burkett the interest
is also significantly up based on this
initial announcement from a national and
global perspective CMU joined several
other top-flight us research
universities in an amicus brief that
provided unique perspectives on the
presidential executive order on
immigration a few weeks ago this amicus
brief contains two paragraphs submitted
by AAU and the ivy plus groups contains
two paragraphs taken from my email to
the CMU campus community in late January
additionally our student leaders have
also hosted an open forum just a couple
of weeks ago to discuss issues of
immigration and on a personal note this
issue is of paramount importance to me
as my personal and professional journey
over the past 40 years were made
possible by the historically welcoming
immigration policy
of this country with that I would like
to thank you for your attention I want
to thank all of you for attending and
those of those of you joining us online
I want to thank you for watching and I
look forward to continuing to work with
all of you to make carnegie mellon
university even greater not just for our
community but equally importantly for
the future of the world thank you and I
look forward to seeing you at the
reception which will follow this
immediately thank
once again our thanks to all of you for
taking time out of busy days to join us
as dr. Suresh said we are going to have
some refreshments and a chance to
continue the conversation informally in
back please stick around and we'll be
around and look forward to talking to
you and we look forward to seeing you at
next fall's Town Hall thank you